entrepreneurs should be able to tell the  truth you should be able to speak to  them honestly they should be able to  take it in  and they should be able to fail even i  mean maybe they're coming to you at the  end of the deal after three years  nothing's working out and my rules are  very simple if you can't make money  after three years it's a hobby it's not  a business i don't know why people give  me crap for this i mean it's so  reasonable but the point is you tell  them the truth  they absorb it they think about it at  least you're dealing in the in the in  the truth and you're not lying to them  but keep going and mortgage your house  and all that but the reason i think it's  more efficient is you only have so much  time to be successful and you don't want  to waste it  there's nothing worse than wasting time  36 months that's enough time to figure  out if a business is going to work or  not right